hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
obscurity okay we're down in the mines
hey gender box we're down in through the
mines and we're trying to find us a
something not this early you dick you're
gonna laugh off [ __ ] oh oh yeah back
off
son you son of a [ __ ] don't think I
don't know what you games your plane
where did you come from you're just
hiding in this corner ah can't hide from
me
well maybe the monster can but that oil
cannot I've been very good about finding
the oil in this game I'm very happy
about that
okay I was about to say the music got
really Clyde there for a second there
and I was a little concerned just like I
usually am I never I played these games
Raja Bhoja oh man I really regret when I
started playing these games with the
music way turned up in my headphones
because it's it's pretty bad okay about
the machine room key Christopher I
accidentally dropped the key to the
machine room into the grate and I have
no way of reaching it if they're a new
one will have to be made we have to find
a way to obtain this one sorry I spit
okay so it's down there somewhere huh
smash I can see the key down there there
needs to be a way to reach it okay take
some rope but a piece of gum on the end
and we're good to go baby spoons or some
other convoluted strategy that I don't
know about do I have anything yeah
whatever what's the point of having a
master key if it doesn't all lock
anything down here and where was that
monster oh this look nice
okay love down giant oh that's thought
that was a bird it's naked people just
like everything else in amnesia everyone
is naked yeah oh look a little string so
I have a piece of gum somewhere see a
hook no anything else in here that I
would need does not look like it oh
hello okay we're good let's go I got the
string put the ball not a push let's see
if we can find some gum what about down
here Oh Oh what did that do okay good so
now it's putting water down there I
maybe it's flooding it a bit I don't
know uh other than that I'm not really
sure if this guy can manage to get that
key out with just a piece of string I
will be very impressed because otherwise
up until this point I have not been
impressed
oops how about a key on a string
really Wow good job man holy crap you're
skilled huh I don't know how maybe loop
the string and fish it down there very
carefully but unless the unless the key
was floating I don't see how that helped
at all okay whatever ignoring video game
logic I have a machine the [ __ ] is that
no thank you
oh honey grab a lemon
[ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]
my angry face don't do that dummy music
got worse it's so loud in my head oh no
no okay
machine room this way I'm a baby I'm a
big baby I'm a big baby I'm a big baby
market lock it lock it behind me ah okay
we're not safe there's no way we're safe
it is impossible that we are safe
this sounds bad
water wheel emergency shutoff well they
couldn't make it a bit simpler could
they just collect all the goodies
because I have a feeling I need to run
out of here ah I can't have on me mr.
oil thank you okay here here we go it's
quiet now
they came from the blackness okay so
that did I don't know I don't know what
the objective of that was what was the
point why did I do that what did I need
to do that
I have anything in my there's my mouse
no mementos oh you think I went down
this way before I think this just leads
in a circle I think I lit these two I
mean as well oh that's right the water
wheeled off and all this water in the
water area
boy I was a long way to go for that good
time I'm not having a good time
oh don't stop me now
okay uh-huh
no surprise chasers out of nowhere
nothing like that we're okay for the
meaning
this isn't good
this isn't good at all this is a
sacrificial chamber I can tell by the
pixels and haven't seen having seen many
sacrificial chambers in my time oh there
we go
we've arrived oh there tell them the
others will be arriving shortly the
ceremony is about to begin
okay you'll be able to leave soon
Elizabeth just lie down on the table and
drink this yes of course you can dear
this will only take a minute
what a dick
all right there's nothing here so let's
just go to the other chambers I do not
like that music by the by it's very
disconcerting oh look another
sacrificial who's it what's it oh good
there's goop all over the floor it's
actually human goop but I will ignore
that for the time being really well lit
with all the candles oh look a prison
cell I wonder what this is for oh hello
thank you
oil in a bucket oil in a bucket oil in a
bucket why was there a little bucket I
don't know hello he's that one there
please help me no who's there no Simon
you said you how did you get down here I
haven't seen you since you were a child
you can't see me now father father
how are you I'm trapped
a rock fell on my arm and crushed it and
I can't move please help me no you're a
dick I'll help you but first you have to
tell me what really happened to
Elizabeth I killed her sacrificed her
I did what was necessary did what was
necessary
what are you talking about you murdered
your own daughter please please
understand they they made me do it I had
no other choice our excuses who who made
you do it the communion I I wasn't too
deep they they told me there's no other
way and why should I trust you
please there should be a saw in the lab
uh-huh I just removed my arm retrieve it
for me and I I'll tell you the rest okay
all right
oh hello a key was slid from under the
door I guess we go to the lab now he
needed to saw why should I trust this
douche he killed his own daughter what
am I to him okay whatever let's just go
to lab and getting it out yeah it's
probably gonna be like that scene from
penumbra Black Plague where I give him
the saw his life yeah and then first out
of the room you know in their room I
didn't even know what he cut off cuz he
seemed to have all of his arms intact oh
well let's just get out of here please
and thank you I want to go home
oh here we go okay here we go lab key
saw so uh not as good as ah there we go
bond saw anything jump to her hiding
place
now down in them I haven't even needed
to use long down on him oh yes I have
because they've hit me a bunch of times
what am I talking about I'm an idiot
shut up I don't know what I'm talking
about
[Music]
when stairs don't work I get angry okay
so we just got to give them the saw and
hopefully you'll get out here I have a
bad feeling about this like all of my
red flags are going up all over the
place this is not there's not a good
idea
[Music]
you said you'd explain everything what
really happened to Elizabeth
I'm not
my god you're not making any sense
what's going on I got to be honest I'm
surprised you believe what your father
done
system sacrificed
uh-huh
okay who are you
orchestra
uh-huh
actions
I just like watching the blood spill
you're crazy
yeah no they could have left
[Music]
by the way I can barely hear him either
I can't keep flipping my foot
[Music]
I'm leaving not so fast
I need to prepare you mother
haha oh hello
oh you ain't so bad you're just naked
that's all you are
get the naked guy I see some bars ripped
open over there that's just a short
little naked guy what am I scared I am
oh baby a push and not much [ __ ] yeah
I'm in love dhanam midair bottle chug
it's never a friggin push goddamn stop
it
you're strong eat you
why am I so damn scared of a one-armed
guy why I've got dorms and four in a
hammer as far as I know I'm pretty
physically fit why was I scared of him
oh no that was carry-on I might be close
to the end of the game so yeah time to
pass out
sacrifice but the names in here and I'll
pick one at random all right let's get
this over with what are you looking at
me like that it's huh that that's not
possible
William you know the rules Elizabeth
must be the next sacrifice please please
don't do this I thank you
sorry but we can't just back out when my
wife was chosen last month I accepted I
I won't let you do this she's my only
daughter
if you resist then I'll make sure that
the rest of your families next it's in
your best interest to just let this
happen
you'll regret it don't
here Elizabeth I want you to have this
necklace it's for your ceremony in a few
days I want you to look nice you'll be
able to leave soon Elizabeth just lie
down on the table and drink this yes of
course you can dear this will only take
a minute
[Music]
what if I don't as I found my way out of
the Lions I decided I'd never look back
I had my answers there was nothing more
for me
I wandered along the road for almost a
day before stumbled upon account they
came back
through documentation and letters I
discovered my mother is still alive
living alone in small flat box she was
surprised to see me and the stress of
old age was replaced relief and
happiness
she took me to Elizabeth's gray in a
telephone person village we stood there
silent
[Music]
at least until the nightmares started
again the dreams they didn't stop
they haunted me like before I just
couldn't seem to let go of my past there
was still something I had to do it was
something I missed weeks past until one
day in the morning paper an article
caught my eye body found mutilated
beyond identification the location was
near Crescent village they were hungry
there were no sacrifices for them to
feed on anymore
I realized what I had to do I pushed for
the reopening of the mines in Crescent
village claiming there was still rich
with materials the newly reopened mind
attracted many workers in their families
desperate to make some money Crescent
village has populated again
[Music]
I started bringing the demons the
sacrifices one by one it was difficult
at first I remembered what the man from
the mines told me the end justifies the
means I realized that this was for the
greater good it had to be
this was my destiny eventually
sacrificing became routine I started
staying to watch the teachers feed upon
their victims such elegance in the way
that would tell the flesh such beauty
when the blood flowed out of streams
they were satisfied
and oddly though as I
[Music]
okaythat's obscurity you're crazy psycho
love adobe all right he's a little bit
nuts oh I'm crazy nutso and so that's
obscurity okay thank you guys so much
for watching and thank you electric red
that was an incredible custom story
I mean um it was really good as far as I
would I don't like to rank custom
stories on a scale I'd like to
appreciate what they have in this one
had custom monsters custom music custom
content and that's what's really
important to make a good custom story
and also it was scary
very very scary and it had great voice
acting that's what I really count is a
good one so like this one the great work
you know the things in the night and any
of the the full conversion was like
tenement tenebrous lake the ones with
like actual new content where the maker
tries really hard to make something
creative and new that's what's amazing
and that's what I really appreciate in
these games so thank you guys so much
for watching and thank you everybody who
had a hand in making this happen I know
having so thank you everybody so much
for watching and click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]